pues de lo que hablan es de como los
países más industrializados que se han
beneficiado de la quema de combustibles
fósiles desde la revolución industrial
pueden ayudar económicamente a que los
países más afectados por esta crisis
climática que es derivada de la quema de
estos combustibles puedan adaptarse y
mitigar los impactos y las pérdidas y
daños ya causados por el cambio
climático que se estiman son de 500 mil
millones de dólares al año esos son los
daños que se estima que causa el cambio
climático ahora cuando el mundo se ha
calentado 1,1 grados por encima de los
niveles preindustriales recordemos que
lo que pretende en estos acuerdos
climáticos es que esa temperatura no
suba por encima del grado y medio oa más
al máximo a los dos grados centígrados
es un tema clave y es la eterna pelea
entre estos países menos
industrializados y que son los menos
causantes de estas emisiones y los más
industrializados que son los mayores
responsables de las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero a locke sharma el
británico del 26 dijo que todos los
compromisos que se están dando ahora
mismo deben ser cumplidos para así poder
alcanzar ese financiamiento para que los
países menos desarrollados puedan
adaptarse al cambio climático y anunció
que reinó unido- colaborará con 400
millones de dólares en ayudas para el
fondo de la adaptación a acuerdos y
fondos para este fondo serán anunciados
a lo largo de la jornada